hello good morning Rishi Scenic
supporters depict him as the grown-up in
the room the technocrats bring in
competence to government and yet British
politics seems anything but inflation
soaring the NHS on the brink nurses
teachers Railway Strikers and postal
workers all going on strike and it
appears the most militant troublemakers
of all are on the back benches of the
conservative party the Prime Minister
must be grateful that the World Cup is
here to distract us and Matt Hancock is
into the final of I'm the celebrity
or we have a big guest list for you this
morning we're going to hear from the
transport secretary Mark Harper on the
show from labor we've got the shadow
leveling up secretary Lisa nandy the
former captain of Wales Laura McAllister
joins us from the World Cup in Doha now
she was stopped from getting into a game
because she was wearing a rainbow hat
we'll see what Greg Dyke thinks of that
he's a former chairman of the fa and
former director of Manchester United and
we'll speak to conservative Rebels
Theresa billias who is pushing the
government to abolish all of its targets
or for building new homes or compulsory
targets so I should say
[Music]
hello good morning well Westminster has
slightly calmed down a bit from the
roller coaster over a few months ago but
things are still far from normal whether
it's inflation strikes pressure on the
NHS or the war in Ukraine plus Matt
Hancock has reached the final of I'm a
celebrity if you ever need a proof that
we are still living in extraordinary
times that really is it well let's crack
on shall we with our first interview we
can hear from the transport secretary
Mark Harper
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning good to have you
here and I just want to start with the
Online safety bill so people who
encourage others to self-harm on the
Internet by social media perhaps now
face criminal prosecution and this of
course comes after the really sad case
of Molly Russell who took her own life
when she was just 14 years old what I'm
confused about is is this just applying
to children or will it cover adults as
well well look people don't have very
much longer to wait the the second day
of debate in the House of Commons on
this important piece of legislation is
going to take place on Monday the 5th of
December in just over a week's time and
as is the proper process ministers will
set out any government amendments
they're asked for the legislation at the
dispatch box in the House of Commons so
you'll just have to be a little bit more
a little bit more patient at the same
time though I mean this has been briefed
out today I'm not just jumping on this
because I want to find out you know you
guys are putting this out today
there's often speculation in the media
about what is or isn't going to be
pieces of legislation this isn't
speculation this has been briefed out
well there's often speculation in the
media I think it's better if ministers
set out any plans that there are in the
House of Commons at the dispatch box
then they can set out all of the detail
about what the government proposes and
allow people to take questions on it so
look it's coming to the House of Commons
I know it's an important piece of
legislation it'll actually be
groundbreaking legislation globally
ministers have worked on it and I know
campaigners like Mr Russell have worked
on it for even campaigned on it for many
years but we're going to have that date
that further day of debate in just over
a week's time um all will become clear
about what the government's plans are at
that point I mean you say it's
groundbreaking and it clearly is you
know lots of parents really worried
about it but not just parents you know
this is something that affects so many
people as well and so I guess that's why
I'm just trying to find out who it
applies to it feels like quite a big
deal to me you know if it's just
children or if it's everybody well look
ministers have taken a lot of trouble to
get this right and they've been you know
there have been lots of people wanting
to make sure we protect children which
is absolutely right and then there of
course been people who are very
concerned about getting the balance
right about free speech so ministers
have taken the trouble to listen to
people's concerns and to get those right
and they'll set out the decisions that
the government's made in Parliament in
just over a week's time so people don't
have long to wait you're talking there
about um people's concerns over free
speech I mean Kevin not for example of
your own a cabinet colleague saying over
the summer we should not be legislating
for hurt feelings let's worry about this
on the conservative side right well look
there's been a debate amongst lots of
people about getting the balance right
now legislation there are no on these
sort of difficult subjects there are no
easy answers it's about balancing
different things that you have to be
concerned about protecting children is
very clearly what the government wants
to do and then it's dealing with the
other issues but making sure that you
don't uh clamp down on free speech so
there's a balance to strike there as I
said the government will set out you
know where where we've made decisions in
just over a week the legislation comes
back for a further
are you not telling us whether it's just
children or
if you don't know or because you just
don't think we should be told yet no I'm
telling you there's a proper process in
Parliament you know as a former Chief
whip I happen to think it's quite
important that when ministers set out
policies uh that they set them out in
Parliament first where members of
parliament can hold them to account on
behalf of their constituents you know
there'll be people in Parliament who are
been campaigning on these issues
ministers can set up the detail because
on these subjects the detail matters
they can set out what the government
proposes in detail and then there's a
full debate in Parliament on Monday the
5th okay now talking about harmful
Behavior there's another story that I
want to talk to you about and this is
the reporting to misogyny and racism in
the London fire brigade and I'll be
honest you know I've been a journalist
for many years I've been genuinely quite
shocked by some of the examples that
this review uncovered you know like a
Muslim firefighter having pork sausages
put in his pocket a woman having her
helmet filled with urine
um Nazir afsel who is the man leading
the review has said that he's been
contacted by lots of people from you
know the BBC the NHS police forces he
wants to see a national inquiry now into
other public bodies do you agree with
him well look on the London fire brigade
issues specifically I listened to the
examples that were set out and frankly
they were absolutely appalling you know
I I worked in business before I was in
politics and that behavior just wouldn't
be acceptable in any workplace
um I was heartened to listen to what the
commissioner of the London fire brigade
said which is that he accepted the
report in full accepted there was a big
job of work to do in his organization
and he made it clear that that that job
started now and he was clear that he was
going to root out people who behaved in
such a way and I thought that was very
good now can you talk about criminal
charges as well didn't he yes and it was
obviously that that inquiry was
triggered by a specific case I
understand of the tragic suicide of
someone who took their own life as a
result of bullying and that's what
triggered the report I don't know of any
similar examples elsewhere so I think
look the important thing here is I've
listened to what was set out in that
report there's clearly some real issues
in the London fire brigade but the
leadership of the London fire brigade
the commissioner has made it very clear
that he he's going to accept all the
recommendations in full uh and he's
going to make it his mission to sort out
that organization and that's the sort of
leadership I think that you want when
issues are identified I guess my
question about why is doing it out is
because it feels like you know whenever
we start lifting up Stones whether it's
in the London fire brigade whether it's
in the Met police this kind of thing is
uncovered shouldn't we start effectively
turning up more Stones elsewhere well
look I think one thing that comes
through very clearly from this and that
came through from the commissioner's
reply is a lot of these things are about
leadership so I think what that report
highlights every leader of every
organization I think should read that
report and just think about whether the
way they conduct themselves and the way
they lead their organization means that
that sort of behavior wouldn't be able
to happen in their organization
but do you think there should be more
inquiries it can't just be happening in
London can it well look that that
inquiry was set up as there was the
response to a specific set of events so
I don't think you want every
organization uh in the entire country
where there hasn't been a specific event
to be setting up inquiries all over the
place but I do think all leaders of
organization should look at that report
and think about whether it could happen
in their organization and if they think
it could then they should think about
what they need to do about making sure
it couldn't okay let's talk transport
shall we are the transport secretary
after all uh the UK is facing more rail
strikes how are your talks this week
with the rmt's Nick Lynch well look if I
just said it in context I think the
difference with the rails uh situation
the rail dispute and the strikes that
have Arisen is that there's some this is
a long-running uh dispute far two long
running actually and what this is about
is about modernizing the railways so
there are a lot of practices in the
railways that we we don't see elsewhere
you know we don't have for example a
railway that runs properly on seven days
days it depends on lots of Goodwill from
workers coming in on days that are what
they what are called rest days so what
we're trying to do
is modernize the railway uh make it more
efficient and make it more flexible to
deal with what passengers need that's
the important thing what passengers need
that then frees up savings and those
savings will then be available to help
give workers a pay rise and also free up
some money that can then go back to the
taxpayer which is having to subsidize
the rail industry so that's what the
negotiations between employers and trade
unions are about and what I what I
originally I met Mr Lynch and Mr Ward
from the tssa this week was to just try
and help move that process so my job I
think is to encourage the two sides in
the negotiations to reach a conclusion
it's not my job to do the negotiations
but I'm very happy on behalf of the
public to do what I can to get us to a
resolution of the dispute so how were
the talks and they can't mean that great
because the strike's still going ahead
well look I think it was the first time
I'd met Mr Mr Lynch and Mr Warden we had
very sensible discussions very
constructive that's what I thought
that's what he thought
um
because he came out onto the steps of
the department after the meeting and
that's what he said uh so I'll take him
with his his word at face value we had a
very constructive conversation uh and I
want to see the trade unions get back
around the table and I hope we can make
enough progress so that they would feel
able to call off those strikes I know
how damaging they are for passengers
also not just for passengers but of all
those businesses I'm very struck by the
hospitality industry uh how important
Christmas is for the hospitality
industry you know I stood up for the
hospitality industry last Christmas when
there were rumors you know people wanted
to close down the country again the
Prime Minister when he was Chancellor
stood up for the hospitality industry
and we want to protect them which is why
we want to see an end to this dispute
um you mentioned there are obviously
strikes going on elsewhere I know
there's a specific situation I should
say with rail workers but they obviously
want to say pay rise as well do you
think public sector workers should
expect to see their pay keep up with
inflation well look I can understand why
that's what people want to achieve but I
think we do have to set in contact so
we're facing very difficult economic
situation uh there's the getting the
economy back on track after the pandemic
there's the war in Ukraine it's worth
remembering that the economy the amount
we're spending on dealing with higher
energy prices it's the equivalent of a
whole new National Health Service right
so that's the economic contest we had an
awesome statement where we got the
public finances back on track stabilized
the economic situation we're seeing
interest rates now not having to rise as
much as they would otherwise have to do
um that that is the context so I think
we want to make sure people have pay
Rises but they've got to be pay Rises
that are affordable for the public
sector and in the The Wider economic
context so are you effectively saying
then that an inflation-matching pay rise
is unaffordable in the public sector yes
I think inflation matching or inflation
busting pay Rises are unaffordable and I
think we want to try and give all the
workers in the public sector who work
very hard decent pay is but they can't
be inflation busting pay Rises it simply
isn't the money to pay for those but at
the same time by the way we haven't seen
those in the private sector either the
private sector pay Rises have generally
been
um settled below the level of inflation
as well which I accept is difficult for
people but there is just some honesty I
think you're going straight with people
about the economic context the country
faces at the same time in the Autumn
saying we did see some inflation
matching increases in people's income so
if you're looking at for example
pensions they're going to rise in line
with inflation benefits too including
out of work benefits you know if it's
good enough for people who are not
working why isn't it good enough for
people who are working well look we we
made a commitment in the manifesto about
the triple lock for pensions which we
you remember we suspended for one year
when there was some anomalies in the
statistics and it was important to put
that back and of course pensioners have
no ability to uh alter their hours or
take any steps to increase their income
and of course a lot most of the people
who are on benefits people on universal
credit for example you huge
proportionism of course which is why I
specifically and they're working on low
wages often and working incredibly hard
to put food on the table and they're of
course on the lowest incomes and it's
the other reason of course why the
national living wage is going up
significantly that'll give her 1600
pound pay rise I think to those who are
on the lowest incomes but working hard
okay and those are the steps the
government can take you've got to be
honest with people you the public purse
won't uh afford inflation busting pay
Rises for everybody in the public sector
okay um just finally on transport we you
know whenever I say that I'm talking to
transport secretary there's so many
people who get in touch with their
horror stories effectively of using the
transport system in the United Kingdom
so I just want to play you one example
of many that we could play Let's have a
listen
yeah I've got to go home and see my son
and I've pre-booked my tickets to get
them cheaper to find out that my train
from here to Doncaster was canceled so I
had to purchase another ticket for 25
pounds and then when I got to the
station this morning at Andover I found
out they've got trained from Andover to
London Waterloo had been canceled so now
I've got a two-hour way between trains
and I've had to I've had to Fork out an
extra 60 pounds
I just want to play this because
everyone's going to have a story like
this you know is our rail system really
fit for purpose look I I completely
sympathize with that woman and her
experience I've had experiences like
that myself part of the point I think
actually all those stories absolutely
back up the case for reform Workforce
reform and modernizing how our Railways
operate I mean at the moment we're far
too dependent on you know expecting
drivers to work on their rest days we
need a proper seven-day Railway that
works efficiently seven days a week that
people can count on for their important
appointments whether it's for family
visits like that lady okay or for going
to work okay now just before we move on
to a little bit uh more detail on the
conservative party just quickly on
manston the Immigration Center we have
had of course reports of someone very
sadly dying from diphtheria has enough
care being taken there well look we take
the care of of people the welfare of
people in our care very seriously I know
the UK Health security agency has been
working very closely with the NHS and my
understanding is the uh the the numbers
of course that Manson have now been
brought back down to the proper levels
on the dip Theory issue there's
extremely low risk to The Wider
Community that's a disease which of
course the vaccination for which is in
the standard childhood vaccination
package so the health security what
about people in these centers you know
there's enough care being taken of them
and their health we take the welfare of
people in our care very seriously my
understanding is those cases were people
who had that disease before they came to
the United Kingdom and of course as I
said the health Security Agency is
working very closely with the NHS to
make sure we look after the people that
have been identified with diphtheria to
make sure that they get the treatment
and care that they need and if they're
identified are they then tracked or do
we keep tabs on them well the
appropriate steps will be taken by the
health security agents the point of
getting the health Security Agency
involved is to make sure we take the
proper steps both to protect the
individuals but also to make sure that
we look after the wider community
now Rishi sunak has been in power for
just a matter of weeks I guess and so
far it's been pretty steady as just as
he goes you know nothing to rock the
markets um one conservative Source
telling the times on Saturday that
boring is the new sexy is it well look I
think what he's about is a government
that's grown up that grips the issues
that people are concerned about gets on
with governing I mean look I accept that
the summer was difficult uh and I think
what we need understatement is get our
heads Down group the issues that people
are concerned about like that lady and
the issue she's got about the rail
service you know that's what I'm doing
as the transport secretary gripping the
issues dealing with them and having a
government that people think is on top
of the issues of the day and getting on
we're sorting them out for the public at
home the only issue is there hasn't
really been anything to move the dial
either I just want to have a look at the
latest poll tracker this is the yougov
tracker poll and you know there has been
a bit of a narrowing you can see in the
polls but it's nowhere near the levels
that you need if you are going to have a
chance of winning the next election I
mean it's boring just the new boring
well look I think if we're being
realistic about it you're not going to
you're not going to turn things around
overnight I think to be fair to the
public the public after the events of
the summer want to see a period of
sensible grown-up government and if I
look at how the two party leaders rate
up between Rishi sunak and Kirsten I
think Rishi zunek has very strong uh
ratings on dealing with the economic
miles behind labor that's the party
thing but the the ratings of the Prime
Minister are actually ahead of the
leader of the opposition you know I
think that that means I think people are
prepared to listen to what we've got to
say but not everyone shares your point
of view but they're going to be look
they're going to be skeptical people are
going to be skeptical about it and
that's fine including we're gonna have
to demonstrate grown-up competent
government and that's how we'll win
people back
um ahead of the next elections
as well though isn't there Esther
McVeigh saying the Autumn statement was
the final nail in the conservative
election chances so John Redwood I can't
believe the Prime Minister will want to
fighting election with Promises of tax
wise as an austerity to come that won't
move the voters back and just to read
out a list of the concert of MPS who
said they're going to stand down at the
next election William ragg Chloe Smith
Gary Street and Nigel Adams Charles
Walker Chrisman blunt Adam Freya to
Hannah Davidson it's not exactly a
glowing vote of confidence from your own
side well look I'll take a couple of
things on the colleagues that are
standing down the reason why those are
coming out all in one go now it's quite
normal that as you get towards an
election various people for their own
reasons decide they're not going to
stand again but there's a specific
deadline in place because of the
boundary changes the parties asked
colleagues to say whether they're going
to stand and set that out before the 5th
of December so you know you're going to
see those all Bunch together so I don't
think there's anything particular to
write home about that on the fact that
we Face very difficult decisions I mean
look the Autumn statement was difficult
I think you know the chancellor said a
number of times that he was having to
take difficult decisions the point of
that is to level with the country about
the challenge we face you know these are
Global challenges the third of the world
is going to be facing recession uh you
know two-thirds of the the developed
countries have inflation above seven
percent facing exactly the same
challenges that we do what the country
wants to know is that they've got a
government and a prime minister that
grips those challenges takes the
decisions that are necessary to get us
on a path for long-term growth and
that's what we saw in the Autumn
statement last a couple of weeks ago now
you're a former Chief whip as you
mentioned earlier in the interview at
Matt Hancock how the conservative whip
suspended when he entered the jungle for
I'm a celebrity but he's now made the
final and so if the public forgave him
do you think the conservative party
should should he have the whip restored
well look one thing is the former Chief
whip is that I'm not going to tell the
current chief whip how to do his job and
look I still hold the position that I
held when I was first asked about Mr
Hancock
um at the beginning if you're a member
of Parliament and Parliament is sitting
I think your job is to be representing
your constituents either in your
constituency or in Parliament I don't
think serving members of parliament
should be taking place in reality
television programs you know however
well they do on them I still think they
should be doing the job for which they
are paid a good salary which is
representing their constituents and you
know that's the position I held but look
The public's going to make a decision
about how that program shapes Obama and
I have to confess I haven't been
watching it so I'm not quite fully up to
speed with what's been going on at the
same time though shouldn't you believe
in second chances I mean you know you
have resigned from cabinet yourself
didn't you after you was found that
you're a cleaner didn't have permission
to work in the UK you're now back in the
cabinet shouldn't Matt Hancock have a
second I think the cheat that's the
decision for the chief Whip and one of
the things I respected when I was Chief
whip was the former Chief whips didn't
tell me how to do my job so I'm going to
let the chief whip make those decisions
I think and I think he'll be grateful
that I'm not interfering understood
thank you very much
uh Mark Harper their transport secretary
um saying that actually in his view
inflation matching or inflation busting
pay rises in the public sector are
unaffordable well it's our chance now to
talk to our Deputy political editor at
Sam coats just to try and find out what
really stood out to him from our main
political interview this morning uh Sam
what did you make of Mark Harper
good morning Sophie well Mark Harper
talked about Second Chances really the
question is whether or not the public
are going to end up giving the
conservatives a second chance what
really struck me wasn't one particular
newsline out of your interview though
there were many it was the tone and Mark
Harper like The Wider Rishi CNAC
government is just adopting a much
calmer perhaps understandably tone when
dealing with problems but it's a lot
more managerial it's a lot less Punchy
it's a lot there's fighty it's a lot
less
um it's not designed to get the kind of
uh the heart pumping and the blood
flowing essentially what they're saying
is we know there are big problems now
give us some time to sort that out and
that's whether that's letting the fire
brigade sort themselves out it's whether
it's sorting out the long-running
strikes dispute it's whether it's a sort
of calmer attempt to deal with public
sector pay they think a new tone will
ultimately go down well with the public
but there isn't much sign to the public
buying it yet when it comes to the wider
conservative party indeed in part this
week there's just been that smell of
death with the number of Tory MPS
standing down Mark Harper rightly says
part of that is because of a deadline
but you've got to look like you've got
to look at questions why young
conservative MPS with a strong
trajectory in a large majority are
standing down if they want uh if they
see the conservative party as a party
with a future I think Richie's cnac's
team needs to make politics a bit more
exciting or otherwise kierstama
previously derided as perhaps the uh
more beige member of the of the fight to
be in number 10 next time could actually
end up getting an edge there you go a
really interesting analysis as always
Sam Sam adapter political editor now
should we get Labor's take this morning
we can talk to the shadow leveling up
secretary Lisa and nandi who joins us
now from Central London now thanks very
much for being with us and we just heard
from you're not in central London I
apologize you're on Wigan and this is
the kind of thing to get very to get
right now we just heard from Mark Harper
he's obviously adopting a softer tone
towards the unions but he was pretty
clear that public sector pay Rises that
match inflation or bust inflation are
unaffordable are they
well well they're unaffordable because
of 12 Years of Tory government and 44
days in which Liz truss and quasi
quateng crashed the economy and I think
there ought to be a level of humility
about that within government what he
should be doing is moving Heaven and
Earth to try and avert strikes coming up
this winter it's been a really tough
year for a lot of people and nobody
wants to see strikes least of all the
people who are having to resort to
strike action it's worth noting that
we're in this position because ministers
have been refusing to meet the workforce
for some considerable time it's very
welcome that Mark Harper has taken a
different approach met with the rmt this
week and by all accounts it was a very
positive meeting but it is ludicrous
that were weeks away from more strike
action and we're congratulating a
government Minister for simply turning
up and doing the very Bare Basics of his
job
at the very beginning that answer you
said that public sector pay Rises that
match inflation are unaffordable because
of the conservatives I'm just interested
in that line because Andy Burnham said
you know he's right behind the nurses
covered claps don't pay the bills are
you saying they're actually
realistically inflation busting pay
Rises including the 19 being asked for
by nurses are actually unaffordable
well look the truth is I don't know the
government hasn't opened the books to us
so in the case of nurses for example
we're not privy to National Health
Service negotiations and it will be
absurd for me to try and conduct those
negotiations live on air what I can tell
you is that if we were in government we
would be treating the nurses as partners
they haven't been on strike for 106
years and they've had to resort to
strike action because the health
secretary Stephen Barkley wouldn't even
meet them over the summer until it was
confirmed that the strikes were going
ahead I was in my local hospital just
yesterday talking to nurses talking to
the management they're trying to work
out how they're going to get through
those days of strike action together and
keep patients safe they would much
rather be at work and one of the things
that we've proposed that would help to
ease that burden is to scrap non-dom tax
status and expand the NHS Workforce
because part of the problem that they've
got is not just that they can't afford
to put food on the table for their
families but they're overworked and
burnt out and they don't know how they
can go on like this
um you were pictured on a picket line in
Wigan with striking workers back in
August would you be joining a picket
line with the nurses
I'm not planning to go down to the
picket line because when I spoke to
members of the Royal College of Nursing
and to the General Secretary of Unison
they like left me in no doubt that where
they want me is in Parliament doing my
job so that they can do theirs and one
of the few people in this country who
can actually demand that ministers come
into Parliament and hold their feet to
the fire we're going to dial up the
pressure on government ministers who've
been utterly complacent in order to get
them around that negotiating table and
get a negotiated settlement it is
possible I know that because I've spoken
to nurses across the country including
here in Wigan in just the last few days
they desperately want to avoid that
strike action and they're only here
after 106 years because of a government
that refused to negotiate with them the
problem in this country is not militant
workers it's a militant government
uh now today you've got some new
research out that you say shows that
leveling up isn't working according to
your analysis uh 568 million pounds has
been lost from leveling up funds due to
inflation so does that mean that labor
would like to spend an extra half a
billion pounds on leveling up
no but we will keep promises that we
make unlike this government they made
huge Promises at the last general
election that they're going to level up
this country and now they've had to pull
their Flagship legislation they've
wasted weeks of council's time on bids
for investment zones that have now gone
into the bin they had 12 leveling up
director posts which they advertised at
the start of this year that are still
not in place and now we've found out
that 560 million has been wiped off the
value of those funds because of their
disastrous handling of the economy it's
a poor port record for something that
was the ticket
to electoral success for the
conservatives at the last election and
at the next election we're going to come
come in win the trust of the people back
and start to set this right
and this week UK net migration hit an
all-time high 504
100
000. is that something we should be
comfortable with because there are
vacancies in the job market or is it
something that labor would like to see a
number that labor would like to see come
down
I think that very high levels of
immigration are unsustainable because we
haven't invested in our young people
we're really proud here in Wigan of the
fact that we're able to attract people
to come from all over the world and work
in our National Health Service but for
young people who live just a few streets
away from our local hospital they might
as well as dream of going to the Moon as
to getting a job there because the
nursing bursary has been abolished and
the education maintenance allowance and
aim higher and all of the things that
built the ladder that helped them to get
there so we believe in an immigration a
points-based immigration system that's
what we introduced when we're in
government but we want to align that
much more closely to skills so that we
first invest in our young people to be
able to get the jobs that exist and then
look to fill vacancies and ask
immigrants to come here because they
make a significant contribution in order
to fill those gaps
there's been a bit of confusion shall I
say and actually from from myself as
well about you know what Labor's
position is when it comes to migration
kissed armor uh gave a speech didn't he
last week to the CBI and the Daily
Telegraph headline was starmer you came
as wean itself of Migrant labor the
headline on the independent was Labor
pledges to relax immigration rules what
is kostama's position on immigration
does he think it's too high or do you
think does he think there should be more
of it
well we want to see the government that
invests in young people in Britain first
and foremost to fill labor shortages but
we recognize too that immigration has a
significant contribution to make not
least at the moment where you've got
short-term gaps in the labor market that
currently can't be filled so last
Christmas there was a consensus that
during the petrol crisis it would be
worth relaxing rules temporarily to get
hgv drivers to be able to deliver petrol
and keep the country moving but we want
to see a sensible approach to
immigration with a plan and at the
moment what we've got this is this
absurd situation where the government
floats these ideas like cutting foreign
student numbers which is their latest
only two weeks ago the higher education
Minister was bragging about the fact
that they'd attracted 600 000 students
to come and study here in Britain a
decade earlier and now we've got
ministers posturing saying that they're
going to crack down on the very people
that just two weeks ago they were
begging to come here we need a serious
plan to fill our labor shortages and
invest in young people here in Britain
not these back of the [ __ ] packet
policies that unravel as soon as they're
announced now you published a book this
week all in how we build a country that
works I just want to read you the first
line of the new Statesman review that
says there's an alternate universe in
which Lisa Mandy won the 2020 labor
leadership election for anyone and
wishing to imagine the kind of leader
she would have been her new book all in
will help so what would be the main
difference in labor policy then if you'd
won in 2020 rather than kirstama
well I think the fact that I'm writing
this book and I was tasked with care in
thinking through how we're going to
rebuild this country from the ground up
drawing on the contribution and the
potential and the Assets in every person
in every part of Britain shows you that
we are a team and that we're drawing on
the strengths of very different parts of
our labor movement in order to speak
directly to the country that it's been a
significant privilege to serve as Shadow
foreign secretary but when I was moved
into this position a year ago it was
because we know that the only way that
we're going to rebuild this country is
by recognizing the contribution that
people have to make in every part of
Britain that's been written off and
written out of the national Story by
this government we're determined to set
this right that's what this book's about
and here is full fully behind the fact
that we've we've got to have not just a
critique of the Tories but be a genuine
alternative that's what he was setting
out this week that's what Rachel Reeves
has been setting out and that's what
I've helped to set out in this book that
was released this week uh very quickly
because I do have to let you go Matt
Hancock know the final of I'm a
celebrity you know politicians normally
get voted out first why do you think
he's done so well
I don't know but I think he should be at
work he's still being paid to be a
member of Parliament and if he's
anything like me he'll be absolutely
overwhelmed with cases of people who
just don't know how they're going to get
through the hardest winter imaginable
because the Tory government of which he
was a central part has crashed the
economy and left people paying the price
and he needs to get out of that jungle
get back to work and start repairing
some of that damage
okay listen Andy thank you very much
indeed
thank you
now in just a moment we are going to
speak to Greg Dyke the former chairman
of the fa and former director of
Manchester United now that club is of
course up for sale I just want to have a
quick look at one of the moments of the
week Mr Glaser why is now the right time
to sell Manchester United hi well as we
announced yesterday the board went
through a process and it's decided it's
going to look at different strategic
Alternatives and that's what we're doing
so United fans say that you should have
sold the club years ago
well once again we've gone through a
process we're going to look at all
different all strategic Alternatives and
we'll see where that leads us so I
appreciate you talking to me tonight and
I'm going to wish everyone a Happy
Thanksgiving Cristiano Ronaldo says that
you don't care about the club and
thousands of United fans agree with him
why why should they be wrong well I'll
tell you about Cristiano Ronaldo he's a
great Manchester player I appreciate
everything he's done for the club and I
wish him the best luck in the future
thanks very much why did he have to
leave the club why did he have to leave
the club
and now for more we're joined now by the
former chairman of the fa Greg dike
lovely to have you on the program uh
good to see you here good morning thanks
for coming on
um we just had that doorstep from my
colleague James Matthews about
Manchester United now of course you used
to be a director of Manchester United I
did all the glazers took over I think
you warned at the time the Takeover
wasn't in the interest of the club are
you pleased to see the back of them oh I
think all Manchester United fans will be
pleased to see the back of them I think
they've
some of what question are Christian
Ronaldo said this week was I thought
quite interesting when he basically said
look going back there after 15 years the
ground has deteriorated the training
ground as deteriorated I think they
haven't spent the money on the club and
they've done it because they've been
taking
a large amount of money out now having
said that football fans would always
want
uh
money to stay in the club and not and
not be paid out to shareholders so but I
do think I think Manchester United fans
generally will be celebrating today I
was interested to hear you mentioned the
Ronaldo interview then you agreed with
some of what he said well I thought his
point about
what's happened to the club over a
period of years I mean there's no doubt
the money has not been invested I mean
Old Trafford used to be you know around
ahead of its time it's no longer like
that uh the training ground is no longer
the world catches up and you have to
spend capital and they haven't spent it
they've taken the money out I just
wonder if there's a bigger Point here as
well not just about Old Trafford you
know in Germany for example they've got
rules to stop a single owner having too
much dominance in controlling clubs
supporters have a much greater role as
well you know is there an issue with
English clubs you know they can be
bought themselves almost like
second-hand cars oh I think there is I
mean there's no doubt uh I mean in
Germany 51 is owned by the fans it was
interesting that when the European Super
League came up there were no German
clubs there involved because their fans
didn't want that I
you I think you've got to look at what's
happened to English who's buying it I
mean my my position is increasingly the
premier league has become to be
dominated by Foreign owners foreign
managers foreign players and so you
think something needs to change what
what do you think should change and who
should try and well I think we're I
think we might be too late oddly in
terms of ownership uh I mean if if the
glaciers sell the club uh for four or
five billion pounds this is what people
talking about then whoever buys it is
going to want some sort of return on
their money they're bound to but you
could change the rules though right
uh it's been difficult to change the
rules if if clubs have changed for that
sort of money how do you change them the
fa can't change it would require uh a
law I think you could say that you could
easily make it that there have to be
fans Representatives on the board I
think that would be good I mean I'm
involved I've been involved with
Brentford which are her now Premier
League club and uh they're fans
Representatives on the board wonderful
Club I've been to a few games at
Bradford to have to say it's well it's I
was chairman for a while for quite a
long while but I was chairman in the
days when we used to have a whip round
to pay the wages today it's brilliantly
run and uh I think it's it's a big
success story yeah definitely I'm Keen
to talk to you about the World Cup uh as
well
um what are you making the decision to
hold it in Qatar
well it was always a ridiculous decision
and it was corrupt basically I mean you
know you have to accept that most of the
people who voted for Qatar
uh or or the executive who voted for it
um most of them were driven out of
football because for corrupt reasons for
corruption uh I it was a bad decision it
didn't meet I mean the FIFA's own Safety
Committee recommended strongly against
it which is why in the end it had to be
moved from the summer to the winter it
isn't big enough it hasn't got you know
if you wanted to put a a World Cup in
the Middle East first of all you'd have
had to accept that it wasn't going to
play in the summer but secondly you'd
have done it through four or five
countries you wouldn't put it you know
the sixth stadium in one city it's an it
was a silly decision I think and that's
before you get into all the other issues
yeah yeah you talk about obviously the
concerns about women's rights about um
LGBT rights as well and we're going to
be talking about Laura McAllister to
Laura McAllister shortly who was ordered
to remove her rainbow bucket hat when
she went in to watch a whales game there
um I'm just interested in you why would
they do I mean that that's just a stupid
thing to do to get a lot of publicity
for something they're embarrassed about
anyway what do you make of the because
obviously there was there was a talk
wasn't there that you know Kane and
others would wear the rainbow armband
they then back down because they would
get a yellow card for it what did you
make of that
well it had to be better organized than
it was if the six or seven European
countries that were doing it had all
felt so strongly about it they could
have said to FIFA
we're doing this and if you don't like
it we're all out of here
and FIFA is not a brave organization but
I mean if you can pick one off after the
other which is what it did it wasn't a
problem but I think if the seven
countries are good the FAS of those
seven countries have got together and
said look we're this is what we are
doing FIFA would have had to have backed
out has it spoiled your ability to enjoy
the World Cup
um not really I enjoy watching football
uh so I and I have watched quite a lot
of games I don't think yet it's a great
world cup but it you know it's very
early days
um
in terms of the football
I I do think
it was a poor decision by it by FIFA and
the original decision and I do think
that is tarnished uh the World Cup this
time and I I would think FIFA who is now
under different sort of management I
think FIFA must be just hoping it's
waiting for it to be over so they can
get back to normal and normal will be
America and Canada is there anyone any
team in particular got your eye on then
who do you think has got the best chance
of winning it
when I when I was chairman of the fa I
set England the target of winning in in
Qatar uh I don't think that's impossible
although I think the fence looked pretty
dangerous yeah uh and Brazil looked
pretty good yeah so you think that it's
not impossible then for England to win
no I think England England uh I mean I
had a very good first game a very
average second game but that's all right
everybody has an average game they
didn't lose uh and I have I I I think
the manager is very good and I think
they've got to they're in with the
chance I think they can well be you know
living with they're one of sort of four
clubs or four countries I think who
could win it now you obviously used to
be director general of the BBC and just
with that hat on I mean there's been a
lot of political debate recently about
the license fee you know the current
culture secretary Michelle Donald
previously dubbed it an unfair tax do
you think it is well it's always been an
unfair tax in the sense that it's
everybody pays the same regardless of
how poor how rich the problem with the
last the issue with the license fee I
believe in the Public Funding of the BBC
whether you can find a better way
uh than the license fee is what the
discussion needs to be about but it's
got to be a better way that doesn't give
more power for the politicians to run to
to influence the BBC is there a better
way that you can see or well I spent
many years I think there are other ways
of funding of funding the BBC from the
public purse
um
but if you look now I personally don't
think this is a big issue now because I
do think we're in the last we're in the
dying days of of this government uh and
I think I mean my impression has always
been that the government of the day in
the end doesn't like the BBC but the
opposition does so the BBC gets a better
period when a new government comes in
and I suspect that's what's going to
happen in the next two years uh just
finally uh the upcoming Media bill also
expected to have a decision on Channel 4
privatization and what's your position
on that well there was no argument for
privatizing channel four it was a
ridiculous uh decision or thought in the
first place and then the secretary said
to had it said well they they if they
get privatized they can they can
challenge uh the big players in the
world that have emerged you know the
streamers
I that was never real the only way that
channel 4 makes any sense if you turn
into a private operation and sell it is
if it's part of something that's much
bigger and I can't see the reason for
doing that okay um really interesting to
have you on the program good to talk a
bit about football as well as important
politics show thank you thank you uh
Greg Dyke uh there now we mentioned uh
our next guest she won 24 caps for Wales
she's a former captain of the Welsh
women's team but when she turned up to
support her country in our world cup
opener against the USA she was told by
security guards that she couldn't get
into the stadium because she was wearing
a rainbow hat
now Laura McAllister who is a gay woman
she described the experiences
heavy-handed
and intimidating I mean you can see
there the Hat
and the experience that she had when she
tried to get into at that Wales game
well she joins us now at from Doha in
Qatar it's extraordinary looking at
footage so just talk us through what
happened you know you're in Qatar as
well as his first match you're in your
hotel room or whether you're staying
getting ready for the match and you of
course put on your bucket hat
yeah well Boda good morning first of all
Sophie yes I mean look I think the first
thing to say is it wasn't just me that
was in that predicament I mean I've had
a louder voice because of my role here
I'm an ambassador for Wales for the
Football Association of Wales and the
Welsh government so I guess I've had a
bigger platform
but there were others in the same
position there were several friends and
colleagues of ours who'd been uh who'd
had their hats removed and confiscated
or indeed in a couple of cases thrown in
the bin which is pretty insulting and of
course the the reality is we we were
told by FIFA before the tournament that
rainbow attire and rainbow symbols would
be permitted inside the stadiums quite
rightly so too so to be perfectly honest
I hadn't really thought that there would
be any kind of issue with entering the
stadium you know we would we were doing
this in a respectful way
um but we were making clear the values
that we stand for as a nation and for us
in Wales you know we're the smallest
country represented in this world cup
that's uh that's actually qualified and
it was really important for us to use
our role in the World Cup as a platform
to show what we're all about as a nation
and that's about human rights for
everyone and not excluding the LGBT
community from that so that's partly why
it was so disappointing rather than the
personal intimidation
what exactly did they say to you I'm
just intrigued you know when they
stopped you and you can see the video
there that happening what was the reason
that they gave
Well we'd had a word passed back to us
in the queue that some of our colleagues
from the faw and other fans had had
issues with their rainbow hat so a
couple of us were standing together
sensed that something was likely to
happen but obviously we weren't prepared
to take our hats off you know as I say
it's a important emblem if you like for
our commitment to Human Rights and and
equality for all but when I went through
the security scanners
um and I came through the other end one
of the female security guards pointed to
my heart and said take off and I said
why you know I have to emphasize we're
being really polite in all of this there
was no point at which we tried to seek
any confrontation I asked why and she
simply replied regulation so I asked
which regulation because obviously you
know I work with the faw and I I'm
involved with UEFA so I do know the
regulations
um and she she couldn't really answer so
another lady came forward and said the
same take hat off or you can't enter the
stadium and again I asked it why and
they simply came up with word regulation
so I mean I stood my ground I just said
I don't know what you're referring to
but by then a male I think he he was
some kind of security manager uh came
around and and pointed again to the hat
and said if you don't take that off you
don't come in inside the stadium
you say you know you obviously did stand
your ground and you are someone who you
know you're a former Captain you are an
ambassador you're someone in a position
of some Authority
but it must have felt quite intimidating
uh well it wasn't the best experience
I've had of going into a a stadium and
you know I've been as well as being
involved in football I'm a fan first and
foremost you know I've been to Wales
game since I was a toddler
um and it's you know it's a pretty
unsavory start to what was the biggest
game in our country's history you know
we haven't been in a World Cup as you
know for 64 years so I was looking
forward to going in with my friends and
my colleagues from the football
association where's the support uh the
the national team so it wasn't ideal but
there's so much else that I think we
have to stand up for in a in a country
like Qatar you know we know all of us
who are here are horribly compromised by
the political regime here we know that
you know they've been such Dreadful
issues around migrant workers we know
that women don't have basic rights as
they do in the west we know as well that
LGBT people are criminalized and so I
think you know for those of us who live
in countries like Wales where obviously
those rights are protected and promoted
you know it is incumbent on us as well
too standard ground and to show that you
know LGBT rights are human rights and
the other thing I'd say actually is that
you know people have said to me
um I think mostly we've had great
support for our Stan but if anyone was
trying to be critical they've said you
know are you not
disrespecting local cultures and Norms
here but I think there's a really
important point there which is this
isn't a Qatari World Cup this is the
FIFA World Cup in Qatar and FIFA is the
organizing uh body for this and they
assured everyone that that everyone
would be welcome that it was a World Cup
for the whole world whoever they are and
whatever their identity and of course
the advice and guidance around rainbow
symbols uh reflected that so I think you
know given all of that it was really
important that we stood up to some
pretty heavy-handed security within the
stadium
it's interesting you talk about people
making that argument and you know on
this program you know I've asked
government ministers about it and
they've said that it's important for
people to respect the laws in their
words of the host country do you agree
with that assessment or do you think
that the UK government should be a bit
stronger I guess
well it's a very delicate balance isn't
it you know I think there's an issue
over awarding uh major events to
countries that can't guarantee basic
human rights and that's one for FIFA
obviously but I mean we have to live our
values whilst we're here you know and
I've had nothing but support from our
government in Wales and indeed from from
the Welsh public and I think there's
lots of people at home who are trade
unionists who are feminists who are LGBT
uh people or activists or Allies and
they felt very uncomfortable about
coming to Qatar so those of us who are
here here in a work capacity have a duty
I think to speak up for them and to show
that you know that there is a an
alternative
equality if you like in our countries
which I think is really important you
know because otherwise how do we ever
have conversations about change and you
know I'm I don't want to be
disrespectful to anyone in Qatar but I
think the very fact that we've been able
to highlight this issue you know people
Qatar people and other nations have
talked to us as Wales fans wearing our
rainbow hats they've talked to us about
what we're about and what those symbols
represent and in a sense that's what a
major International Sports tournament
has to be about as well because there's
no there's no doubt at all in my mind
you know that it's nonsense to suggest
that politics and Sport are separate
they're not and that's the reason why
the world cup is here in the first place
of course so equally you can't then
remove politics once we come to a state
like Qatar and expect us not to be true
to the values that are important to us
in Wales and and of course in England
and in other countries which have much
more Progressive attitudes to this and
fair play to you as well for you know
doing this interview you're there in
Qatar and you are you know sort of
taking on if you like some of those uh
prejudices by giving us your view as
well and players have been registering
their protests in different ways we've
had some teams for example covering
their mouths to show that they couldn't
stay at what they wanted to but they've
stopped short of you know wearing the
rainbow armband and taking the yellow
card as punishment
do you think there should have been a
bit more I guess coordinated action we
had Greg Dyke on the program earlier he
said that look if people have been a bit
more organized all of the European teams
for example coming together saying that
they would have worn the rainbow armband
then actually
um they'd have just had to swallow it
well I think there's a few things to say
there you know I think it was
fundamentally wrong of FIFA to
intervene in the players environment on
Match day I mean that's unforgivable you
know the players are here to play
football and whatever the issue they
shouldn't be conversations with players
about what they wear on the field of
play on the day of a match or hours
before kickoff which of course is what
FIFA did with England and and indeed
with us in Wales I think we'll have to
reflect on this when we get back you
know because I know that Gareth Bale the
the Wales Captain was
extremely keen and enthusiastic to wear
the one love arm band you know he felt
it was an important reflection of the
the stuff that I've been talking about
really what what our nation is all about
um but I think you know you have to
recognize as well that FIFA were
threatening Beyond red cards you know
they kept it an open-ended threat from
what I gather that it could be Beyond a
yellow card so who knows how that would
have played out and I think that's
fundamentally wrong you know we've put
in the players in a really invidious
position we learn lessons from it
because I think in unity there's
strength and the Seven National
associations those who've got
Progressive equality
approaches should have probably thought
about a plan b or what might happen
given we hadn't hadn't had a formal
response from FIFA about the one love
Arm bans but you know we will reflect on
that certainly in Wales where these
these matters these matters are very
very important to us but but I have to
say you know as a former player myself
on Match day you know the attention of
players should be on the biggest game in
their careers and for those Welsh
players you know they were the first
players to represent Wales in a World
Cup for six decades and I know they
wanted to do their best on equality
issues but it was very very wrong of
FIFA to put them in that position
talking about the biggest game of
people's careers at Wells of course
playing England I'm not going to ask if
you're going to watch the game because I
certainly know the answer to that one
um but do you think well they've got a
chance of beating England
well of course we've got a chance
um but we're going to have to play a lot
better than we've played in the first
two games
um I think the fans will they won't be
optimistic but they'll still believe
I've spoken to a lot of my friends who
are here who still think that we can get
a result against England we've got to
Hope of course at the Iran USA game is a
draw then but you know we we haven't
beaten England for a long time so we do
we're do a win but you know make no
mistaking that England are a great team
they've got strength in depth they've
got such quality on the bench and at the
moment we're not firing on on Old
cylinders but but things change very
quickly in football you know if we go
out and put in a performance yes we can
beat them but you know I think from most
Welsh fans perspectives it's the
performance now we've been disappointed
on the pitch for whatever reason and I
think if we can go out and play well and
with real passion and energy against
England I think the result will come but
even if it doesn't come uh the fact the
fans will be proud of the the team and
go home you know happy that we've shown
what we're about out on the world stage
um great thank you so much for being on
the program today you know you've been
such a sort of strong voice for equality
and for you know the values that you
clearly hold very dear as well in Qatar
say thank you
thank you
could talk a bit about football on the
program where football and politics have
certainly have been colliding in recent
weeks now back to the pure politics of
Westminster politics because a big
Rebellion is brewing on the leveling up
Bill more than 50 conservative MPS have
signed an amendment to abolish mandatory
housing targets now that of course could
tear up Boris Johnson's Manifesto
commitments to build 300 000 new houses
a year to help ease the housing crisis
last year they managed not much more
than half of that with just over 175 000
new builds in England but we're joined
Now by Theresa Villas the concept of MP
behind the amendment good to have you on
the program so what's the idea for the
amendment Festival
the amendment is to return local control
over planning decisions to local
communities these targets I think are
based on 2014 out-of-date population
figures they're disproportionately
um pushing for delivery in the crowded
Southeast and to meet those Targets in
the Southeast there's a danger that we
essentially risk making the same
mistakes as the 60s and 70s with
high-rise high-density blocks Greenfield
development all of which would be
damaging to our environment and the
quality of life of many people the
government's Now set to pull the votes
completely tomorrow do you see that as a
victory I think it is an important
Victory and I really welcome the
government's decision on that because
they were sending a clear signal that
they wanted to look at these issues
again and the secretary of state has
subsequently been out on the airway
saying he really understands our
concerns and he wants to to try and
provide some reassurance so I hope that
does happen and have you been talking to
ministers to get the reassurance that
you want oh actually again and again and
again over over a period of years and
and that will obviously continue because
I mean we can't continue as we are I and
many of my colleagues have felt like our
constituencies are under siege of course
we need new homes but they need to be
the right homes in the right places and
they need to be supported by appropriate
infrastructure so in your conversations
have you seen a shift more recently then
in the government's attitude on this do
you think
well in his public comments the
secretary of state has has repeatedly
said that you know things do have to
change and there needs to be a response
to these back bench concerns it remains
to be seen what that response will be I
hope I hope we do see some serious
change because I I am Gravely concerned
about the impact on the environment of
these targets and how they're operating
at the moment so you've obviously got
concerns about the environment concerns
about constituencies like your own but I
just want to read to you from the last
Manifesto you know the Manifest that you
stood on we will continue our progress
towards our Target of 300 000 homes a
year by the mid-2020s this will see us
build at least a million more homes of
all 10 years over the next parliament in
the areas that really need them now you
know as I said an introduction you know
last year there was just over 175 000
new houses built in England that's not
much more than half the target you've
got to do something about this haven't
you well removing mandatory targets
won't mean that house building grinds to
a halt the actually local councils it
might be doing well actually do some of
the introduction the mandatory targets I
mean we just have to look for example at
the experience of local plans which are
in local neighborhood plans where you
give communities in a relatively small
area more control and power
responsibility over home building and in
those instances they've really stepped
up local decision making taking
communities with you is a way to deliver
new homes we also need to see homes
being much more Central to the
government's regeneration of of towns
and cities around the Midlands and the
north they can be a positive part of
leveling up whilst at the same time
taking the pressure off some of the hot
spots across the rest of the country
particularly the South and London come
on you can't really expect us to believe
that you know local residents can be
like yep let's have loads more homes in
our communities that's not how it works
you know in in many instances of course
local residents will accept new homes
but it's they have to be supported by
appropriate infrastructure and and it's
not um it's not acceptable where these
where these new homes cause significant
environmental damage we need to get a
better better balance and a fairer
distribution of new homes across
different parts of the country you know
there's so many young people who are
struggling to get in the housing ladder
rental prices are soaring what reason
are you giving those young people to
vote conservative
because the conservatives are the party
that could be trusted on the economy
because we're going to get taxis down
and yes because we're going to help more
people on the housing ladder we will
continue to deliver new homes that that
is absolutely the right thing to do and
removing mandatory top down targets is
is not going to stop that it just means
that we'll need to take communities with
us in terms of housing delivery so
housing is something which is done with
the consent of local communities not
done to them I just want to read you a
quote by Saturday David who's written in
today Sunday times he says he's dismayed
by your Amendment and he says it would
put meaningful policy into reverse we
risk creating a generation that turns
its back on the politicians who failed
them a generation that without any
capital of its own becomes resentful of
capitalism and capitalists has he got a
point uh I I disagree with with sajid's
approach I I think you know future
Generations won't thank us if we destroy
the environment in in the calls of
building new homes we can deliver new
homes we can do it in a sustainable way
with the consent of local communities
and uh I think the better way to do that
is to remove these top-down targets and
give more power agency and
responsibility to local communities at
the minute it feels like the attack line
that kirst armor is using again and
again on Rishi Cena is that he's weak he
says that pretty much every prime
minister's question if he's pulling
legislation because he can't get his own
back benches like yourself to support it
doesn't that just play into Labor's
hands
I I don't believe it does I think the
postponement of the vote that was due to
happen tomorrow is a senseful decision
it demonstrates a prime minister and
ministers who are willing to listen to
the concerns about Ventures made on
behalf of our constituents and just
finally well I've got you Matt Hancock
is going to be is in the final of I'm a
celebrity do you want to see him win
well I I think it would be great to be
one I have to say when it first started
I found it very difficult to watch but
he's done fantastically well I've
certainly been voting for him and I wish
him well with the final oh great I love
it then we've got a bit of an insight
into the who's voting for Matt Hancock
why did you find it difficult to watch
at the beginning
well I I mean I suppose it's a fairly
sort of excruciating sort of thing to
see people people go through buried
alive or gunsed or yeah made to eat
various parts of animals anatomies but
he's he showed incredible resilience and
bravery going through those those tasks
and people can can see him for the you
know the the engaging and you know
and and sort of a great human being that
he is okay thank you very much for being
on the program today Teresa Villas uh
well that is it for this week's safety
Ridge on Sunday real range of stuff on
the program today in a moment after the
break we're going to be running through
today's interviews talking about what we
learned with adaptive political editor
Sam coats we've also got the podcast as
well the social region Sunday podcast
should be available around lunchtime
today that's with me and after school
correspondent Liz Bates thanks for
joining us this Sunday morning
[Music]
hello good morning and welcome to Sophie
Bridge the take where we take a look
back in a bit more detail at some of the
subjects that we've been talking about
with our guests in the last hour
um we've been talking Lots about
politics of course you know transport
whether it's strikes and lots of lines
on that but we were keen on the program
as well to talk about football with a
World Cup but also the politics behind
it too so we had Laura McAllister you
know the former captain of the Wales
team he was actually kicked out of the
stadium opening story not kicked out but
she had her rainbow bucket hat
confiscated but when she tried to watch
Wales in Doha and we also spoke to Greg
Dyke the former chairman of the fa who
had some pretty interesting things to
say about the World Cup and the decision
to hold it in Qatar well let's bring in
our Deputy political editor Sam capes as
usual uh shall we now Sam you know I'll
let our views into a little secret you
basically told me not to ask you
anything about the World Cup on this
program earlier in the week in here well
I wanted to talk about Greg Dyke what's
going on
I know
um well look Sophie let's put it like
this there are two effectively reality
TV gruesome spectacles at the moment and
and to be honest as you say I'm actually
not watching either of them one of them
you've been talking about all the way
through the show and that's Matt Hancock
on I'm a celebrity uh get me out of here
and I haven't watched him do any of
those trials but what's been interesting
is how politics is laced through that
has he been undergoing something of a
public Rehabilitation what role does
politics play in something like that he
could win which is pretty extraordinary
for what two weeks ago was one of the
most unpopular politicians in the
country but the bigger a wider political
story is the World Cup in Qatar and that
too is something of a spectacle where
the politics is absolutely critical to
what's going on from the sheer number of
global politicians that have descended
on qatars the amount of money that's
being spent there but there are big
questions about whether or not it was
the right decision so I just thought the
most striking moment for me this morning
was a man who's won many many hats in
his time Greg Dyke particularly
ex-german of the Football Association
saying this to you
well it was always a ridiculous decision
and it was corrupt basically FIFA's own
Safety Committee recommended strongly
against it which is why in the end it
had to be moved from the summer to the
winter it isn't big enough it hasn't got
you know if you wanted to put a a World
Cup in the Middle East first of all
you'd have had to accept that it wasn't
going to play in the summer but secondly
you'd have done it through four or five
countries you wouldn't put it you know
the sixth stadium in one city it's an it
was a silly decision I think what do you
make of the because obviously there was
there was a talk wasn't there that you
know Kane and others would wear the
rainbow armband they then back down
because they would get a yellow card for
it what did you make of that
well it had to be better organized than
it was if the six or seven European
countries that were doing it had all
felt so strongly about it they could
have said to FIFA
we're doing this and if you don't like
it we're all out of here
yeah some pretty strong words there from
uh Greg Dyke when it comes to the World
Cup I mean I'm someone I have to admit
Sam who's been watching both of the
gruesome reality TV spectacles of I'm a
celebrity on the World Cup as you put it
avidly
um I'm interested to get your view on
the great diet line because he's very
critical isn't he the government line so
far has been look you have to respect
the law of the host country do you think
that's good enough
um well listen I actually thought that
Greg Dyke said something even more
devastating he said that the England
side that uh other significant countries
could have done more to stand up to the
Qatari authorities over the business of
wearing uh the rainbow armband in effect
they had more leverage than they used to
stand up to the qataris but by
implication he said they chose not
really to go toe-to-toe with the Qatari
authorities and I think really Sophie
that's kind of the story of this World
Cup when you look at actually what's
going on out there and there's a
fascinating piece in the Sunday Times
today it talks about the U.S Secretary
of State the British foreign secretary
flying out with congressmen with MPS in
order to have political talks and kind
of big up Qatar when you're out there it
talks about how the British Council a
sort of arm of the British government is
advertising the UK about how Britain's
more than just about fish and chips out
there because it wants to present a good
face to Qatari investors and how
critical Qatar is when it comes to the
Middle East the bottom line is Sophie
that whether it was the original
decision in the first place to hand the
World Cup to Qatar or whether it's the
way that those kind of protests that
have fizzled out have been handled
actually for all of the warm words for
all of the uh for the good wishes and
the virtual signaling people aren't
really standing up to Qatar they're
letting it do what the Qatari World Cup
was always designed to do which is to
promote that country warts and all on
the world stage and make it a more
important Global Center so yes there's
kind of complaining around the edges but
but nobody nobody is actually standing
up to them and so quite a lot of what
seems to be going out there is hollow
words because we don't want to use the
leverage that we have it does have been
quite extraordinary doesn't it uh where
you get mega stars like Gareth Bale or
Harry Kane saying yes we want to wear
the one love armband and yet not for
whatever reason feeling that they're
able to do it and it's um always good to
talk to you about football more football
questions to come on the show for you
and there was lots of other things on
the program today that was more pure
politics I guess more Westminster
politics and the shadow leveling up
secretary Lisa nandy was one of those
who joined us this morning I talked to
her about strikes and whether or not she
thought the pay Rises that unions are
asking for are affordable or not just
give you the context first it came off
the back of the mark Harper interview at
the transport secretary where he said
that inflation matching or inflation
busting pay risers are not affordable
look the truth is I don't know the
government hasn't opened the books to us
so in the case of nurses for example
we're not privy to National Health
Service negotiations and it will be
absurd for me to try and conduct those
negotiations live on air what I can tell
you is that if we were in government we
would be treating the nurses as partners
they haven't been on strike for 106
years and they've had to resort to
strike action because the health
secretary Stephen Barkley wouldn't even
meet them over the summer until it was
confirmed that the strikes were going
ahead
uh Lisa and Andy uh they're on the
strikes let's bring Sam back in and it
feels to me like labor is walking very
careful type right here they want to
show that they're on the side of workers
who are obviously grappling with Rising
inflation that they feel their pay
packets aren't keeping up with but
they're not in any interviews committing
uh to you know backing the actual pay
Rises the nuts and bolts of why they're
going on strike
I think it was absolutely right Sophie
there's a much bigger picture here and
and it's a shift from a labor party that
really smells an opportunity uh to get
into power and wants to close down many
of the lines of attack by the
conservatives I just thought it was so
important to hear Lisa nandy nandy say
two and two things well important to
note that the labor party are doing
these two things the first is to say
very very bluntly uh we cannot say at
this stage we would give public sector
work nurses public sector workers
inflation League pay Rises labor is not
saying that and that's very very
important it might be the position that
the unions want them to it might be the
position that the public expect them to
take but they're saying no for the very
clear purpose that they think they need
to be better trusted with people's money
with public money than they were perhaps
in the Jeremy corbyn days and then you
had Lisa Mandy who herself had been on
the picket front line had join strikes
saying she E2 wasn't going to join the
nurses on the picket front line and all
of this I think is part of Labor
thinking it needs to shut down possible
Tory lines of attack ahead of the next
election and there was another one this
morning and that was Lisa nandy saying
uh that there wasn't going to be a
bonanza on immigration if labor comes in
they weren't going to allow lots of
people in instead they were going to try
and find ways of better using British
workers for British jobs in effect that
Gordon Brown slogan they don't repeat
that but essentially looking ways of
better using the domestic Workforce in
order to fill gaps in the labor market
these things are all part of a very
concerted attempt by the labor party by
kirst armor to say things that they
think the public want to hear and to
shut down effectively differences with
the conservative party they're all
basically Tory positions those three
things don't join the picket lines don't
offer public sector uh workers inflation
linked pay Rises and don't uh open the
floodgates to immigration to deal uh
with the job market vacancies that
businesses say that there are and by
really matching tool repositions bluntly
that's that's what it is that's one of
the things that kirstanbra is doing now
in this phase of his leadership of the
labor party uh to try and get into Power
a really interesting to see you can
definitely see as you said the kind of
the tactics coming into play is that
election and the possibility of power
starts to become uh you know something
that they see it's a realistic
proposition uh Sam always good to hear
you announcements we'll have more uh
from Sam after the break when we are
going to be hearing a little bit more
from Mark Harper the transport secretary
who was our main government interview
today
hello welcome back to Sophie Ridge on
Sunday the take where we take a pause
take you back through some of the most
interesting parts of the mornings uh
interviews and we get some analysis from
our Deputy political editor Sam coats
and now we've been talking a lot about
football but one of the other really big
subjects that we're covering this
morning has been public sector pay lots
of strikes of course a wave of strikes
as the newspapers will put it coming at
this winter and the transport secretary
at Mark Harper had some pretty strong
words to say about public sector workers
who are asking for a payroll is linked
to inflation let's listen to what he
said
I think inflation matching or inflation
busting pay Rises are unaffordable and I
think we want to try and give all the
workers in the public sector who work
very hard decent pay rise is but they
can't be inflation busting pay Rises it
simply isn't the money to pay for those
at the same time by the way we haven't
seen those in the private sector either
at Mark Harper they're being very clear
that he thinks that they are
unaffordable let's bring some coats in
shall we
um you heard they're the transport
secretary saying look we've got to be
honest with people inflation busting pay
risers are unaffordable where do you
think the kind of public mood is on this
well I think that there is quite a lot
of public sympathy for individual
particularly nurses and some of the
other medical profession professionals
um but sympathy for strikes does go down
uh for isn't there for for every single
profession but but we're talking just
before the break Sophie about how labor
basically has the same position as the
conservatives uh there which is not to
promise inflation busting uh public
sector pay Rises for anybody and there's
a secret basically about this debate
there's a there's a thing that
politicians know that they think the
public haven't quite caught on to and
it's one of the reasons why both the
main political parties are acting as
they are and and it's buried in some of
the documents that were released
alongside the Autumn statement that
Jeremy Hunt did about 10 days ago and in
that statement Jeremy Hunt revealed that
the office of budget responsibility sees
inflation around about 10 now as price
is going up 10 a year
um and that's why there's all this
demand for a big public sector pay
increase but the truth is that by the
end of next year so by the end of 2023
the officer budget responsibilities path
for inflation it basically suggests that
it'd be right back down to quite close
to two or three percent in other words
there is a temporary problem with wages
lagging massively behind inflation but
both the political parties are putting
some faith in the obr who are
essentially forecasting that problem is
going to go away before the next
election and that's why ministers are
being quite tough they think by the time
uh of the next election actually those
pay Rises will be ahead of prices and
labor feel that they can do that as well
and so they think that politically the
issue of public sector pay is a Year's
worth of pain facing down those wanting
more but partly because they can't
afford and tactically partly because
they want to show that they're tough on
the public finances labor aren't going
any further than the conservatives but
they think that this problem won't be
there by the time of a 2024 general
election but that's a BET right Sophie
that's a bet that actually prices don't
continue staying inflation doesn't
continue staying High because of ongoing
problems with Russia and Ukraine it's a
back that that's uh when the Gen next
general election is that it we last with
this Parliament until 2024 and I think
that you can't be certain about that but
that managerial approach from the
conservatives I think is uh currently
made easier by the fact it's matched by
the labor party but that a different
kind of tone from Mark Harper uh I think
that we were talking about earlier I
think is really striking and there are
some conservatives worried uh that
actually the Rishi sunak uh Premiership
is a little bit bloodless that they want
to look like they're fixing problems
behind the scenes they'll know they'll
be unpopular for a short period uh but
this is the best way to win that public
trust uh when uh as the voting intention
polls show that you uh showed earlier uh
the labor party are so far in front
let's hear Mark Harper deal with exactly
that is the richest United Premiership
exciting enough
look I think what he's about is a
government that's grown up that grips
the issues that people are concerned
about gets on with governing I mean look
I accept that the summer was difficult
uh and I think what we need
understatement is get our heads Down
group the issues that people are
concerned about like that lady and the
issue she's got about the rail service
you know that's what I'm doing as the
transport secretary gripping the issues
dealing with them and having a
government that people think is on top
of the issues of the day and getting on
with sorting them out for the public at
home the ratings of the Prime Minister
are actually ahead of the leader of the
opposition you know I think that that
means I think people are prepared to
listen to what we've got to say but not
everyone shares your point of view look
they're going to be skeptical people are
going to be skeptical about it and
that's fine including we're gonna have
to demonstrate grown-up competent
government and that's how we'll win
people back
it's interesting isn't it um whether or
not the kind of study as you goes
approach is the right thing to do to try
and you know get a bit of stability back
after frankly completely Bonkers a few
months in Westminster or if actually
they need to take some risks to do uh
better which do you think it is then
I think that Richardson needs to show
that he can impose himself on the party
whether it was the housing debate you
were having with Theresa Villas whether
it was some of the discussions around
brexit that we were having this time
next week it's not clear completely to
me that Richie sunak can command the
conservative party yeah and there are
just some straws in the Wind of problems
to come on
yesterday's times suggested that allies
of Boris Johnson are suggesting and get
this and it's hard to get your head
around that they are suggesting Boris
Johnson could mount something of a push
as soon as after the next local
elections now that feels incredibly
unlikely to me but the fact that there
are some people saying that and
potentially even believing that is a
marker of how unstable it is below the
surface I have found conservative MPS
who do think that Boris Johnson might
want to come back at the very latest
after an election as leader even though
the maths on that again confuse me and
it seems very hard to do you and so this
question of strength which is being
weaponized by the labor party who are
turning it into a question about whether
Rishi sunak is too weak to lead is going
to be something potentially that dogs
the party and calm managerialism Steady
As She Goes trying to fix intractable
problems which is Richard Cena's
instinctive way of governing his
instinctive way of doing politics may
not match the kinetic Sound and Fury
that we have over the next few weeks and
months yeah one of the things that stood
out to me from the Sunday papers
actually was saying that labor are
trying to basically make use the word
weak as much as possible in relation to
Rishi Cena even though it's not
something that is actually really coming
up with focus groups they think if they
say it enough then it's gonna stick
exactly and you hear it every week now
from kirstama prime minister's questions
it's that charge of being weak and the
problem Sophie is that some Tory MPS
agree because they feel that they can
pressure Rishi neck into doing what they
want they feel that without a proper
mandate because Rich you see that was
never voted in by Tory members he is the
third prime minister in this Parliament
he is weak in that sense that they can
exercise power over him he's got to show
that's not true oh thanks very much Sam
always good to talk to you as some coach
that our deputy just about it well
that's it for safer Ridge on Sunday the
take this morning do check out the
podcast you can hear back all the
interviews if you miss them plus a bit
of analysis from herself and Liz Bates
have a lovely Sunday thanks for tuning
in see you next Wednesday 9pm for safety
Ridge the take
foreign
[Music]